Nick what do you got for me buddy hey
I'm I'm Nick um
kind of lame introduction anyways uh uh
I had a question um about to turn 35
I had ordered your book
and before it came in I got a false d uh
D DV charge oh okay so I kind of saw it
was coming but I'm a is this a
girlfriend or is this your wife wife I
got six okay seventh one on the way you
got six with one on the way yeah I'm a
pastor that whole career got nuked oh
wow yeah so
uh are you guys in the middle of a
divorce I hell I have no clue I can't
even talk to her okay okay
yeah so all right so what's the ask here
tonight just any advice uh moving
forward
um been dropping a lot of weight
well uh I mean where do you live do you
live in Canada or the states
um I'm gonna have to move why you gotta
move
um I don't know anybody here but really
no friends no family well I mean if you
want to be around your kids you're going
to have to stick around to where the
matrimony home is going to be they
already moved oh your kids have moved oh
so she's left yeah yeah where do they
move to uh Louisiana
so you basically got to move there yeah
I don't want to though
yeah
well
um I don't know have you talked to a
family lawyer uh not a family lawyer but
I'm in contact with a lawyer you should
you should first thing you should do is
talk to a family lawyer probably in
Louisiana
um maybe you might have to deal with it
with both States I don't know but um
yeah I mean my friend you are in the
middle of a divorce what it sounds like
uh well it is that's what's happening
yeah taking your kids and left and she's
filed a DV charge which is a trump card
they used I mean I'm assuming it's a
false DV charge it is it is so it's it's
the trump card that women use to screw
over the uh kid's father to get him out
of the house and give her control yeah
you are in the middle of a divorce
um I look if you're not on my email list
you should be here I'll put it again
down on the bottom Banner again but get
on my email list because I have the
divorce course ready it's it's done and
I'm gonna put a 50 a 50 off coupon code
to be used 20 times for the first 20
guys to get in right it's priced at 497
so that means you'll get it for like
248.
um get on the email list you'll have an
opportunity to grab it it's it's got all
the details you need to know to navigate
where you're at right now because uh I
mean like the longer you leave this the
like the the more you're kind of up in
the air about well I don't know where I
am or if I'm really getting divorced no
you're you are in the middle of a
divorce you are currently separated she
has filed a DV charge and taken the kids
you are
quickly going down the road of being
completely [ __ ] here and really not
seeing your kids in her extracting
resources from you so take it seriously
talk start by talking to a lawyer okay
talk to a family lawyer take it sir I
mean you want to be involved in your
kids life and you want to make sure you
don't get wrecked you're gonna have to
start taking this seriously okay like
and the other thing that I'll say
because I know a lot of guys that are
uh men of God and religious you know
sort of thing as I like to be the nice
guys this is not this is not the time to
be chivalrous this is not the time to be
the nice guy this is the time to be firm
I'm not saying be an [ __ ] or go are
your way to make life you know difficult
or anything like that but this is not
the time to be chivalrous okay okay
all right so take it seriously
um and yeah if the course appeals to you
it's it's not expensive and and it
covers like literally everything I've
learned over the last several years my
own divorce consults with other guys
working with family lawyers I spent
three hours with my lawyer actually
structuring this course we put
everything together so it's not going to
be specific to Louisiana but it's
specific to female nature and the way
that that the West generally treats the
divorce process you're going to need a
lawyer in the state that you're going to
have to deal with it in to deal with
like exact family law issues but the
mindset around what's happening where
it's going to go and what you need to do
is all in that course material okay all
right I appreciate it all right Nick
good luck with that thank you
yeah that's uh
I often say that there's these like
frying pan to the forehead moments
and uh
that I hope for Nick is a frying pan to
the forehead moment man if you're if
your wife uh you know files a false DV
uh charge which is if you guys don't
know what that is that's where you
haven't done anything wrong like this is
how it typically goes down guy walks in
the front door of the house his wife's
on her cell phone at the front door or
maybe somewhere in the house goes yes he
just got home he's threatening to hurt
me me and the children are very scared
and he's looking around being like what
the hell's going on what are you what
are you talking about I just got home
yeah send the police right now and then
they just take him William cuffs because
all she has to do is point and sputter
and say I am scared man bad take man
away and then that gives her control of
the kids she can change the locks on the
house in many states and provinces get a
restraining order or just leave the
state in this case this is what's you
know what's happened with this guy six
kids and one in the oven and she's done
all this to him dude's a pastor like are
you like he doesn't sound like a bad guy
to me
so that's what a false DV charges I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out